comme on est dans une émission de télé
est ce que vous accepteriez par exemple
puisque maintenant vous allez aussi
produire et vous avez déjà produit plein
de gens très talentueux d'être jurée
dans the voice par exemple si on vous le
proposait badens se voit il se met deux
peut-être faire une émission à moi dans
le genre ouais bah ouais pas de chercher
une chaîne groupe à producteurs en
france
mais voilà non mais j'avais ce projet là
avant qu est donc match sur canal + sur
ses vols
mais à ma sauce un peu plus ouais mais
que rap ça c'est bien pour garder le
moment toutes musiques confondues uk
pour canal+ ça serait énorme tas
paraîtrait dedans ah bah oui sinon ça va
fonctionner un petit truc un accord de
principe à une exclu une exclu
d'abaisser ce serait intéressant mais je
pense que ce serait très fort et je te
dis pour canal plus ce serait un beau
projet parce que canal+ typiquement
c'est une chaîne où on doit pas voir on
donnera des trucs qu'on voit pas
ailleurs at war bon bah on doit le voir
que sur canal+ pour moi en france voilà
après s'il fait d'autres trucs et on est
meilleur en france et c'est canal+ kelly
alors vous êtes assez discret sur votre
vie privée sentimentale etc
on connaît vos rapports dans la musique
avec les femmes que ce soit dans
l'équipe ou dans les sons quels sont vos
rapports en privé et dans l'intimité une
position rêvée rapports avec les femmes
comme tout le monde je comprends pas la
question parce que j'ai des relations
non non c'est dans vos clips et dans vos
sont bas les femmes c'est gros plus
grosses fesses
on les tartines donc est-ce que c'est
pareil aucune grosse façon les tartines
en prix mais c'est ça mais je vous
respecte les femmes ouais c'est vrai je
respecte la vie en général comme plantes
animaux tout mais moi je voudrais dire
et on habitue géant victime père fidèle
au six mois je suis je suis entier c'est
ça je suis sincère jeu est simple en
fait
non mais c'est vrai et voilà qu'on ya un
gars voilà quand et avec un gâteau avec
lui tu étais sait-on cadre de nous alors
c'est pour ça que je supporte encore
moins la trahison c'est ça c'est bon
pour moi un des spectaculaires ces
marais nathalie vous avez souvent mis
l'argent en avant dans vos clips
pouvez vous nous dire à combien s'estime
maintenant votre votre fortune
aujourd'hui s'attarder vraie question
est la deuxième nation est ce que tu
penses qu'on peut me faire un pot commun
talent et de mère selon vous qui est le
meilleur rappeur français aujourd'hui et
qui est le pire le meilleur de sa
génération girex et niño ok on embrasse
le berry rien n'a trop rien dire si tu
dois sortir kara no 1
ouais celui qui semblait quasiment
tenait à sa se fait pas celui du moment
où je sais pas julie flinguer sa
carrière c'est vrai ouais ouais ouais
franchement at-il sur la retraite j'ai
essayé de partir en douceur est n'est
pas la retraite du tout tu mon nagra
sera quand tu dis ça quel dommage déjà y
avait payé le dixième album qui sort ce
soir à minuit et je t'explique là déjà
ça va être bon certains cartons pulsé